wenn ich e-mails von deutsch lernen lese
oder wenn ich eure kommentare bei
youtube lese dann gibt es einige fehler
die mir immer wieder auffallen einige
typische fehler die deutschlehrer machen
und einer von diesen typischen fehlern
ist die verwechslung von ab und wenn ob
ich durch sprecher kann ich in
deutschland studieren wenn ich deutsch
spreche kann ich in deutschland
studieren
in diesem video erklären wir euch den
unterschied zwischen orts und wenn und
zeigen euch wann man welches wort
benutzt wenn euch das video gefällt dann
gebt uns bitte einen daumen nach oben
und abonniert gerne unseren kanal dann
bekommt ihr auch in zukunft immer
benachrichtigungen wenn ein neues video
rauskommt los gehts jetzt was ist das
schwieriger an wenn und ob wann und ob
können beide im englischen mit if
übersetzt werden und das macht es so
schwierig die regel wenn man wenn und
wann man ob benutzt ist aber eigentlich
ziemlich einfach
ob benutzt man immer dann wenn man einen
zweifel ausdrückt oder wenn man zwei
optionen hat wenn benutzt man in allen
anderen fällen
ich weiß nicht wen ich morgen kommen
kann
ich weiß nicht ob ich morgen kommen kann
ja
in diesem satz drücke ich einen zweifel
aus ich weiß nicht ob ich morgen mit
kommen kann
deshalb benutze ich hier ab kommt vorbei
ob ihr wollt kommt vorbei wenn ihr gold
in diesem satz drücke ich keinen zweifel
aus ich drücke lediglich eine option aus
wenn ihr wollt dann kommt vorbei ich
benutze daher hier wenn und hier noch
ein tipp für alle von euch die englisch
sprechen oder gelernt haben
immer wenn man im englischen ist und
wafer benutzen kann benutzt man im
deutschen ob kann man also mit webber
und übersetzen wenn hingegen kann man
nur mit if übersetzen
ob du mit kunst komme ich auch mit wenn
du mit kunst komme ich auch mit janis
schweiz nicht wenn er eine oder zwei
kugeln eis kaufen soll
jan ich weiß nicht ob er eine oder zwei
[Musik]
ich bin nicht sicher wenn das eine gute
idee ist
ich bin nicht sicher ob das eine gute
das war unser video zum thema ob versus
wenn wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
dann abonniert doch gerne unseren kanal
easy germany das geht hier und dann
bekommt ihr immer benachrichtigungen
wenn wir ein neues video draußen haben
und zum weiteren deutsch lernen
empfehlen wir euch unbedingt unsere
website link könnt ihr unter anderem die
wichtigsten deutschen grammatik regeln
lernen und zwar durch kleine interaktive
video geschichten
außerdem findet ihr einen vokabeltrainer
und ein gender trainer mit dem wir die
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln und auch
die artikel zu den deutschen nun
kennenlernen könnt wir freuen uns wenn
ihr das ausprobiert und wir freuen uns
auch wenn wir uns am sonntag zu unserem
nächsten video wiedersehen tschüs und
schönen abend
[Musik]